لم يستطيع حكم القيء المانيا والارجنتين
في مونديال السويد عام 58 تمييز الوان
قمصان اللاعبين لشده تقاربها الابيض مقابل
الابيض
اجراء قرعه الزمت القرعه الارجنتين
بارتداء القميص الثاني لكن ما حدث بعد ذلك
كان غير متوقع فما هي المفاجاه التي كان
يخفيها منتخب التانجو والتي اجبرته على
فعله لا يطيقه اي ارجنتيني تبين بعد
القرعان منتخب الارجنتين حضر الى
المونديال واحد فقط فوقعوا بحرج شديد لكن
سرعان ما تدخلت اداره نادي السويدي
استعاره لاعبوا الارجنتين زي الفريق
المحلي الشهير بكم صانه الصفراء وهو اللون
المميز للغالين التقليدي المنتخب
البرازيلي يستكمل اللقاء وتنهزم الارجنتين
بثلاثه اهداف لهدف ولتكون المره الاولى
والاخيره التي يلعب فيها المنتخب
الارجنتيني باللون الاصفر
[موسيقى]